[Music]
you mentioned earlier
the question of
what happens if this goes right and i'm
paraphrasing but like what does this
look like say five ten years down the
line even more if this goes right
could you speak to
the practice of
pre-mortems and pre-parades if i'm
getting the term
correct
correct
it was actually a technique that i
picked up from larry summers
so
former treasury secretary summers is on
the board with me at square and he
actually joined pretty early he's been
on the board for almost a decade with me
now
and he posed this as a challenge to the
management team at square about
imagine things go incredibly well over
the next three or five years
actually write it down don't just think
about it write down what does that look
like what does success really look like
what does the company look like what
have you achieved
which markets do we operate in which
products have we shipped
then go write a pre-mortem
things didn't go the way you wanted to
what does that look like
and so we've taken that concept we
actually use it in our investment memos
so for every investment we contemplate
we write a pre-mortem and a pre-parade
and when we've had strategy offsites for
for ourselves for the square capital
investment team
we did this too we had a pre-mortal but
literally it said 2030 autopsy of
sequoia capital and what went wrong what
all the things are going to cause us to
not be a great firm in the future and
the the value of this exercise is again
back to the insights from don
it really crystallizes first order
issues
because you can spend all your time
scurrying around doing all the busy work
if you're not focused on the things that
will really compound and matter over the
next five to ten years you're missing
the boat and it's the urgent important
trade-off and it's all those things
woven into a very practical exercise
how often would you do the
pre-mortems
at the sequoia
i suppose team off sites
right every two years
every two years i think every year is
too frequent because things things don't
just don't change that often i mean we
may revisit something if there's
something that's really changed
there's a why now why now is one of the
questions we'd love to ask obviously
like why now so you know we made an
off-cycle decision to open up in europe
for example something we hadn't done for
a decade we kept on thinking about
should we open up an office in in europe
should we be on the ground instead we
kept on flying into europe and we made
some great investments we were early
investors in unity and klarna and you
know several other companies
on the continent and at some point we
realized there's just so much company
formation happening in in europe and
especially after the global financial
crisis the the there's a whole crop of
young people in europe that now aspire
to building companies when that wasn't
the case before so we revisited our
assumptions and changed and that was an
off-cycle decision
let's dig a little bit deeper on the the
pre-mortems specifically as applied to
sequoia
so let's just say
you're
at an off-site and let's you can pull a
real one to mind
and you're asking yourselves you know
imagine the venture business in 10 years
time
sequoia is gone
what happened
are there any
answers that you can brainstorms that
you can share that prove to be very
valuable in decision making for the firm
because i will say for people who don't
know the venture capital
ecosystem
one
thing of many that has impressed me
forever for as long as i've known about
sequoia is the longevity
of sequoia
are there any examples that you could
give of pre-mortem answers that have
proven very important in decision making
for sure by the way the
long live
you know that the sequoia tree is the
longest live tree in california i do
right and that's the reason that don
chose to name sequoia sequoia
it was an accident he wanted the
partnership to outlive him with a lot of
consequent behavior and actions and he
also wanted us to invest in companies
that stand the test of time which i
think we've done disproportionately so
you know the couple of things from the
offsides you know
i think one of the most important ones
is hubris
you know the downfall of every greek
tragedy
and the extent to which we rest on
yesterday's success you know one of my
favorite quotes is
no wreath
bolts as fast as one that's rested on
we cannot rest on the past and it's part
of what motivated me when i joined
square by the way i you know the motto
we have inside our building is you're
only as good as your next investment
and i saw that hunger and determination
from people like mike moritz and doug
leone who clearly made it in life and
yet they were relentless in the pursuit
so very important for us as a team to
think about hubris
we need to make sure that we continue to
meet companies at the earlier stages of
formation
so
when you go back when we made if you
think about the history of sequoyah's
investments when we invested in atari or
apple or cisco we were the first
investors they were often single digit
numbers of people around the company
when we first invested we invested in
youtube there were three people linkedin
there were seven people palo alto
networks one founder in our office
incubating him
if we start losing grip of that early
stage of being in touch with
entrepreneurs right at inception that's
very dangerous for us there's this
temptation to then drift downstream and
become a late stage investor and so
that's probably one of the most
important things we talked about in the
offsite is we've got to make sure that
we stay at the fountainhead of company
formation
you